ANDREW JESSUP: OK, let's
get started.
So, good afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for coming
down today.
When we manage to pull a crowd
on the afternoon session of
the second day of a technology
conference, I think that means
we're doing pretty well.
So thank you for coming down.
Thank you to everyone on the
live stream, as well.
I know some of you've gotten up
very early in the morning
or stayed up very late in the
evening to watch this.
It's really exciting to see
you all here, either
physically or virtually.
We've got some really cool
stuff to show you.
So, my name's Andrew.
I'm a product manager on the
Google App Engine team.
I work with the runtimes teams
here in San Francisco.
I'm going to be your, I guess,
"cabin assistant" for the next
30 minutes or so.
And at the controls here at the
front, up on stage, is our
highly-experienced pilot for
this session, who's also the
lead engineer on what we're
going to show you today, Mr.
Stuart Langley.
STUART LANGLEY: Thank you
very much, Andrew.
It's great to see so many
people come down who are
interested in PHP.
Obviously this session was
formerly known as the new
language for App Engine.
And as [INAUDIBLE], excuse me,
announced yesterday, we've
actually launched PHP
for App Engine.
It was a very exciting
time for us.
And it's good to see so many
people interested.
But before we can really get
started on the topic of the
presentation, there's one final
thing that we'd like to
do before we get into it, which
is actually mark the bug
in the issue tracker as
officially started.
As engineers, we like to measure
our milestones as
"acknowledge," "track", and then
"finish." Unfortunately
we can't say "finished" but we
can definitely say "started."
While Andrew gets us on the way,
I'm just going to jump
into the issue tracker, here,
and let the people that I know
at I/O and perhaps haven't been
watching the news for the
last 24 hours or so, the most
popular feature, or the most
requested feature ever in the
history of App Engine has been
delivered, and progress
is on the way.
So, Andrew.
ANDREW JESSUP: This is a big
moment for us, guys.
OK, so 3,300 people, I think,
started that feature.
PHP is now available on
Google App Engine.
So PHP is the most popular
language, by many accounts,
for writing software
for the web today.
And that's perhaps not
particularly surprising.
It's a language that, from
day one, was designed
with the web in mind.
It was designed to make it easy
to stand up anything from
a web form to rich complex
applications, things like
content management systems or
e-commerce sites, or even
back-end enterprise
office software.
And Google App Engine, of
course, is a platform that
allows you to take your code in
whatever language it might
be written in and bring it
to the web with Google's
infrastructure, the same
infrastructure that we use for
products like Gmail, and
Maps, and Picasa,
and many other services.
And what we're going to show you
a little bit of today, at
least give you a taste of, is
how you can use some of that
same power, some of the same
phenomenal elastic bursting
capability that App Engine
gives you, some of the
phenomenal availability and
reliability that App Engine
gives you, as developers,
with PHP, with your own
applications.
So I can stand up here
sermonizing for awhile, but
why don't we just get
into the meat of it?
Why don't we get into a real
dilemma on PHP, Stuart.
STUART LANGLEY: Actually, before
we get to the demos,
why don't we try and answer the
question that most people
probably on the tips of their
minds, which is how have we
gone about bringing
PHP to App Engine?
Are we using something
like HipHop?
Are we running an App Engine?
Are we running something like
PHP in a JVM on top of Java in
an App Engine?
Or even something more
exotic than that.
And quite often, the
simplest answer is
often the most correct.
And what we've actually done is
taken the open source PHP
5.4 interpreter that you would
get from PHP.net, downloaded
that and hardened it to running
in the App Engine
environment.
So the good news there is, if
you have an existing PHP 5.4
application running somewhere,
it will be very
straightforward for you to
actually forklift that
application into the App Engine
environment, to take
advantage of App Engine
services, and the Google Cloud
Platform as a whole.
So now that we know it's open
source PHP 5.4, the next
question that we can answer is,
what extensions have we
compiled into the interpreter?
What's available for you as
application authors to use
when you're running your
applications for App Engine?
So at this point we
can probably jump
into a quick demo.
Looks like we actually updated
the bug, which is good news.
So what we have to demonstrate
this to you is a really simple
web shell application
running--
look over this way--
PHP 5.4 in Google App
Engine 1.8, which is
what we just released.
And what I can do here is ask
it to tell me the extensions
that are available.
So because my live coding skills
are somewhat sub-par,
I'm going to do a cut
and paste here.
But essentially we're just going
to get what extensions
have been loaded, sort them so
it's easy for us to have a
look what's there, and then
print them on the screen.
And if you're actually hitting
this application now, which is
running on appspot.com, you
might be getting an error or
two, basically because I've
locked it down so only I can
access it at the moment.
But I will fix that shortly.
And this application will be
available to everybody.
So now we see what extensions
we've got available here.
We think we've sort of captured
a reasonable set of
extensions for the most common
peer-to-peer applications that
are being written today.
We have APC, so you have opcode
caching available, GD
for graphics, with JPEG,
PNG, and free type.
And for application
interoperability, we have XML,
SOAP, and Opus, Open SSL.
And obviously for SQL, we
have the three variants
of the MySQL API.
So I figure there's probably
an easier way that I could
have shown you this information
because PHP comes
with a built-in function which
will actually show you a lot
more about the interpreter than
I could ever hope to say
standing up here in half an
hour, which is obviously PHP
info, which is probably the
first script that anybody ever
using PHP would write.
But running it in the shell
here, with the output going
into our terminal windows,
not very informative.
So what I was thinking we might
do to illustrate how
easy it is to develop
applications for App Engine
and to test them locally and
to push them up, is to
actually add a page to our app,
here, which will run PHP
info and push it up, let people
hit that page, and see
what's there for themselves.
So if you're familiar with
developing apps for App Engine
using Python and Java, you're
going to be very familiar with
the next steps I'm going
to show you.
But I'm hoping there's a bunch
of devs in the audience, who
are watching online, that have
never tried App Engine before.
So I'll take three minutes of
your time to add a new page to
my App, test the App locally,
and push the App up to
production, make it available.
And while I'm at it, I'll remove
the restriction that I
had before so that anybody
can use the application.
So this is basically the
listing of files
that are in my App.
We have a few PHP files and some
static resources that we
use, as well.
The interesting file that you
might never have seen before
if you've never developed
for App Engine is
the app.yaml file.
So we can quickly have
look inside of there.
And essentially, what this is
is the configuration of your
application so that we know
how to host your App.
For a simple application like
the web shell App, essentially
it's the metadata at the top
which is describing the name
of the App and the runtime
that this application is
using, in this case
the shiny new PHP.
And the bottom section is
essentially the handler
mapping, which we used to map
incoming URLs to either static
resources in your App or to
the scripts that should be
executed when those
URLs are accessed.
So what we'll do, we'll quickly
add a new script.
And this is where talking is
going to be interesting.
So quickly add a new
script to call PHP
info when it's accessed.
Could not be simpler.
And now what I need to do to
get this to work with my
application is actually add a
new section to the handle, the
section at the bottom here,
which will map an incoming
request to that script that
I've just created.
So let me just go down.
Looks like I can't cut and
paste for some reason.
So we're going to type.
So what I'm going to do is
create a mapping from a URL
PHP info to execute the script
PHPinfo.php that I just wrote.
And I promised you that I'd
remove the restrictions that I
placed in this application from
anybody using it, which
is actually the bottom line in
the app.yaml file here, where
I've said that only
administrators are able to
access the last URL, the
front page of the app.
I'll just go ahead
and delete that.
And save my app.yaml.
So I think my app's ready to go
but I don't want to push on
production what I
haven't tested.
So what I'm going to do is use
the dev app server tool that
comes as part of the SDK that
you download to write Apps for
App Engine.
And what dev app server is is
a complete simulation of the
entire production environment
that runs on your machine
without you having to have
gone and configured any
services that we might
have running.
So for example, Memcache or
task queues or Chrome or
things like that all work on
your development box and you
can debug PHP apps without you
having to actually retrieve
the services yourself or set
the binaries up yourself.
So my development
service started.
And the most important line is
the second-to-last one at the
bottom, which is it saying it's
waiting on 8080 on local
host for request for
this application.
So what I'm going to do is just
jump over and go to local
host and we can see the same web
shall that you saw running
in production, running
on my local machine.
I've got a slightly more recent
version of a PHP on my
local machine.
But the host has now changed
to Development 2.0.
The app works, as you would
expect it to do in production,
on my local machine, here.
So what I didn't mention
before is this
app's actually stateful.
And between requests, we can
assign values to variables and
then get them on
later requests.
And we do that using Sessions,
PHP developers are obviously
very familiar with sessions.
But in this case, it's backed
by Memcache And so I have
Memcache running in my local
environment, here.
Everything's working fine
without me setting it up.
But we're not testing
the show.
We're testing that the
new script that
I added works correctly.
So let's hit PHPinfo,
and you can see it's
going to call my script.
And it's actually showing you
PHPinfo for PHP that's running
on my local machine.
So I think that I've
successfully added my script
and I've set up the
handle for it.
So let's push it up
to production.
The way that you push
to production--
I'll sort of type and talk
at the same time.
Here's another tool that
you get with the
SDK, which is AppCfg.
And the AppCfg looks at the
app.yaml file that I showed
you before to understand the
structure of your application
and how we should deploy
that up to production.
And to make sure that you put
your study cases in the right
places and your [INAUDIBLE]
in the right places.
Well, that was quick.
So it's pushed my App up
to production already.
It's actually even already
checked if that vision that I
pushed up is serving
back to me.
So what I should be able to do
now is go back to my instance
that I have at appspot.com,
and hit PHPinfo.
And there we have it.
So I've successfully deployed
a new page to my App, tested
it locally and pushed it up to
production in hopefully three
minutes or so.
And as I mentioned, this should
now be freely available
to anybody to go and try out the
interpreter and actually
have a look at the PHPinfo for
themselves to see what we've
actually provided in
the interpreter.
ANDREW JESSUP: So that's
a great demo.
But I mean, let's be honest.
There's probably not that many
people in the room who make a
living out of pushing minishell
applications up.
And we did promise everyone
a real application here.
Have you got--
I don't know--
have you got Wordpress or
something like that
that you can show?
STUART LANGLEY: Funnily enough,
Andrew, I thought you
might ask if I had Wordpress.
And as it turns out, I do.
Let's just have a quick look.
We'll do this really quickly.
This is not a Wordpress
demonstration.
It's an App Engine
So what we have here is
Wordpress running on
appspot.com.
This is already public.
You can go and have a look at
gaeforphp-blog.appspot.com.
But that people that have
deployed Wordpress sites
before would recognize this is
basically what you would see
when you first deploy a fresh
site and you haven't
configured it or haven't
changed the
themes or the styling.
And so we're using basically
the theme that
comes out the box.
And we haven't made
a post, yet.
But a blog without a post is
a pretty lonely old place.
So let's quickly just jump
in and make a post.
Once again, if you've used
Wordpress before, you'd be
familiar with the Administration
Console, which
is where you go and configure
everything and do your posting
from configure your plug-ins.
And we're going to do a post.
So we'll jump in the
post-tabs here.
And luckily enough, I've already
pre-canned something
and have it ready to go for
the purposes of the
demonstration, which
is a new page.
Andrew checked this
out before.
And he's happy with
the content of it.
And what I'm actually going to
do, as well, is use jet pack
to make a tweak when we
do the post, too.
And so on the side, here, I've
got my Twitter settings.
I'm pretty happy with the
hashtags but I just remembered
that I forgot to add Andrew and
his legions of followers
to the post, here.
So let me just add that in.
And hit "Publish".
And Wordpress will go off and
do what Wordpress does best.
And publish our post.
We can see at the top, there,
it's saying "Post Published,"
"View Post".
Let's quickly jump in the front
there and look at our
front page and hopefully we'll
see our shiny new post.
There we have it.
Wordpress post working.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW JESSUP: So this
is Wordpress
running on App Engine.
And by the way, these sites
are both live that we've
demonstrated to you.
So both the blog,
gaeforphp-blog.appspot.com and
php-minishell.appspot.com.
They're both live now, if you
could get through the Wi-Fi.
want to go check them out.
Now when Stuart showed me
this demo a few weeks
ago, it blew me away.
And the reason why--
and if you've ever tried to
stand up something like
Wordpress, then you'll
know this--
to run something
like Wordpress,
actually, it takes PHP.
But it takes a lot more
than just PHP.
It really takes a full
stack of services.
In fact, it takes what you
might call a platform to
really pull an application
like this together.
For one thing, you
need a database.
And not just any database,
but you need a
fully-relational database.
And one that understands a
pretty sizable subset, if not
the full subset of SQL commands
that these kinds of
applications have
come to expect.
Fortunately, we have that in the
form of a product called
Google Cloud SQL.
We'll talk a little bit about
that in a second and some of
the optimizations that we've
made for Cloud Sequel and App
Engine and PHP in particular.
Another thing you need to
do when you're running
applications, very frequently,
is write to some
kind of file system.
And historically, if you've
worked with App Engine then
you'll know that's
been a challenge.
We don't allow rights to the
local file system that your
application's deployed on.
We do that for reasons of
security as well as reasons of
scalability.
But we do need somewhere
to write files.
If we wanted to upload an image
as part of the blog
post, for example, we'd need
somewhere to put the image.
We'd need somewhere to serve it
so our users could see it.
So we need a scalable
distributed file storage
system and we have this, of
course, in the form of Google
Cloud Storage.
Again, we've made some
optimization so that it works
well with PHP.
We'll talk about that
in a second, too.
And then finally, when setting
up any application there's a
ton of other services that tend
to come in pretty handy.
Things like Memcache for adding
efficiency to your
application.
Things like a mail service that
can send mail reliably
and efficiently.
Things like task queues that
allow you to dispatch and
asynchronously run long-running
processes.
Again, we'll-- very briefly,
because I know we want to get
to questions--
we'll very briefly cover
some of these, as well.
So let's start with
Cloud Sequel.
So CloudSQL is our fully-managed
MySQL
5.5-compatible database
service.
And the key phrase in there
is "fully-managed".
You don't need to shell into an
instance and set up a MySQL
server and configure it and then
write a backup script and
then set up read replicas and
all that sort of thing that
you would normally need to do
for a reliable MySQL cluster.
This is fully-managed.
You go into the Cloud Console.
And you turn it on.
It's really simple.
It's also highly durable.
What that means is when you
write to Cloud Sequel, we
actually propagate that right
out to multiple data centers.
And that gives you what I, being
a product manager, like
to call "meteorite-level
reliability." In other words,
if a meteorite happened to hit
a data center that your app
happened to be serving
out of, you wouldn't
necessarily lose any data.
And in fact, your app would
still keep serving.
We provide automatic backup and
one-click restore, which
if you've ever tried to roll
your own backup system, you'll
come to appreciate
very quickly.
We also have a really
interesting
pricing model with CloudSQL.
With CloudSQL, you can price it
on a per-hour basis in the
same way that you would
do with many other
hosted Sequel services.
But we also have a pricing model
that allows you to pay
for CloudSQL only for the
increments of time that you
actually use it.
That is, the increments of time
that you read and write
to the database.
And if you have staging
databases and QA databases and
maybe even development databases
floating around that
you don't actually use very
often-- maybe only a couple of
hours a week, or a few
hours a month--
that's actually really
economical.
You could save a ton of money
by using CloudSQL and using
that pricing model.
But most importantly, I think,
for this audience and this
talk, we've optimized it for
use with Google App Engine.
We've done that in
a couple of ways.
We've optimized the security.
You specifically bind a CloudSQL
application to an App
Engine app, which gives you an
extra level of security over
and above what MySQL
itself gives you.
We also optimize it
for performance.
And we do that by co-locating
the CloudSQL instance along
with your application.
So that the application you're
running in and the database
you're using are physically
proximal to each other so that
connections between them
are very fast.
So that's CloudSQL.
But let's look at what it
looks like inside PHP.
Now, if you've ever worked with
MySQL in PHP before--
I'm sure many of you have--
then you'll know, first of all,
that PHP makes it easy.
But second of all, that PHP
makes it easy with three
different libraries.
There's the MySQL library, the
mysqli library, and PDO_MySQL
library, and possibly others.
And the good news is, with App
Engine and CloudSQL, we've
optimized it to work with
all three of them.
And in fact, there's not really
much to say about this,
except that it works exactly
the same way that you would
expect with a MySQL database
that you might have running on
your own instance or running
on your own box somewhere.
The only real difference is
that, rather than specifying
the main server or an IP address
of a MySQL server
somewhere, instead, you specify
the project name and
the instance name
of the CloudSQL
instance that you've created.
And this socket CloudSQL
identifier, here.
Everything else--
querying, selecting
a database--
is exactly the same.
So that's CloudSQL
in a nutshell.
Let's talk about file storage.
So again, with file storage,
we wanted to file an
object-store system that was as
scalable and efficient and
performant as App Engine
itself was.
And Cloud Storage
gives us this.
It has a couple of pretty
interesting features, one of
them being fine-grained
access control.
So like any file system, really,
it gives you the
ability to be able to control
exactly who can read and write
to what files and what
collections of files.
It also allows you to publicly
publish content to the web if
you choose.
If you set the bit on a
collection of files or on a
specific file, you can publicly
serve that image to
the web from a HTTP address
that you've been given.
So it's actually great for
storing content that might get
uploaded as part of your
application or generated as
part of your application.
And then there's many different
ways that you can
get to those files once
you've created them.
There's a web-based GUI, if
that's what you like to use.
There's any number of RESTful
APIs that the Cloud Storage
service gives you.
And then, of course,
you can get to it
from Google App Engine.
Now let's look at some code for
getting to Cloud Storage
from PHP in Google App Engine.
So PHP has a number of functions
that support a
streaming API.
Within the streaming API, you
can specify what resource you
want to access by the
URL you provide.
And you've probably used
these functions before
if you're PHP developer.
These things like fwrite
and file put contents.
And you might have used them
with URLs like a file path or
possibly an actual URL,
like HTTP URL.
What we've done with Google
Cloud Storage is include Cloud
Storage as a first class
citizen in the streams
interface, which means,
effectively, that you could
specify a Cloud Storage object
or a Cloud Storage bucket with
these calls.
So to write to a file is as
simple as if opening a Cloud
Storage bucket that's been
set to be able to
talk to your app.
You can then write data into it
just like you would write
data into a normal file.
And you close it just like you
would close a normal file.
Similarly, functions like file
put contents and file put
contents work much the same way
as if you're working with
files on a local file system.
And the good new thing about
that is it makes it really
easy to put content and retrieve
content from this
high-performance storage
system that we have.
So that's a couple of ways that
we've talked about to
store data.
Let's very quickly talk about a
couple of ways to make your
application more efficient.
And again, for those of you who
might not have used App
Engine before, or you have but
maybe it's been awhile, both
of the features that we're
about to talk about are
fully-emulated, not just inside
App Engine itself when
you push your applications
to production.
But they're also fully-emulated
inside the
development server itself.
So you don't need to set
anything up on your laptop or
on your development
box in order to be
able to use this stuff.
It's automatically there with
a development server.
So the first thing I want to
talk about is Memcache.
Memcache is a great way to
store content you need to
access frequently and you
need to access quickly.
Session data is something, for
example, that you might want
to store inside Memcache.
Something that's computationally
expensive to
produce, maybe something that
involved a few database calls
or a few CPU cycles is something
to you may well want
to store inside Memcache
between
requests or between sessions.
One example, actually, the we
showed you before we didn't
tell you was the blog we set
up was using a Memcache
plug-in called back cache
to cache the pages
that have been generated.
And that actually worked,
interestingly, out of the box.
We didn't need to
modify any code.
And in fact, PHP provides
two libraries
to work with Memcache.
It provides the Memcache
library and
the Memcached library.
They're similar but different.
And all you really need to know
about how they're treated
inside PHP on App Engine
is they work
exactly like you'd expect.
And again, we've found a lot of
code that we've worked with
generally works by simply
dropping it in.
We don't need to make any
modifications to it.
So another way you can add
efficiency to your
applications, as well as some
scalability and some
reliability is using
task queues.
Task queues are possibly
my favorite
feature of App Engine.
And in a nutshell, what a task
queue is, if you haven't used
it before, it's a way of taking
a long-running piece of
work-- let's call it a task--
that you would have otherwise
running inside the
request-response cycle
of your application.
And it might delay the response
to your users while
you're waiting for this
task to complete.
And task queues allow you to
take that unit of work and run
it asynchronously outside of
the request-response cycle.
And what that means is,
instead of waiting for
long-running processes to
complete, your application
could respond much more
quickly-- it can respond,
effectively, immediately--
to your end users.
So they get a snappy response.
And they get a much better
experience using your service.
So again, just a little bit
of context in here.
An example of that might be when
Stuart published his post
on Wordpress before, we actually
had a little plug-in
there called jet pack which
allowed us to tweet to our
legions of followers.
And you might've noticed, when
he pressed "publish," it
actually took a short
amount of time.
It took about a second or so.
Which is pretty fast.
But the reason that it took so
long, a large amount of that
time that we were waiting was
actually waiting to go out to
the Twitter API, send a tweet,
get a response back.
Twitter has a great API.
It's pretty fast.
But calling any third-party
service takes time.
So something like that is an
ideal thing to wrap into a
task and to run asynchronously.
Let's quickly look at some
code that does that.
And this is rather contrived
code because we wanted to fit
on the slide.
But I think we can
get the idea.
There's really only two steps.
The first step is to create
a task handler.
This is just a normal
PHP file.
And all we've done inside this
task handler is put the code
we would like to have executed
asynchronously.
In this case, it's the code
that send a tweet.
And we want this task handler,
we don't want to send just one
particular tweet.
We want to be able to
parametrize it so it can send
many tweets.
And so what we've done here as
you can see, is that the text
of the tweet is specified
by a post variable.
And then, back in the original
code that was publishing,
publishing a blog post-- here
we've called it post.php--
what we've done is take the
original code that was sending
a tweet and replace it with
this new push task object.
So we include the push
task library.
We instantiate this
push task object.
We initialize that object with
the path to be handler that
we've just created.
And we set at any parameters
we think are important.
Again, in this case, the
text of the tweet.
And we call this add
method on it.
And that add method will then
execute very quickly.
It will asynchronously dispatch
the tweet task.
It will run outside of the
request-response cycle.
And your application can
get back to your
users really quickly.
So it's a really nice way of
improving performance.
You can also take advantage of
things like retry in the case
the tweet call happened to
fail for some reason.
Now, there's a ton of other
stuff that I was hoping to
have time to talk about today.
There's things like our page
service, which automatically
rewrites your JavaScript and
CSS and HTML so it renders
quickly for your users.
There's things like a URL fetch
service which actually
takes the same infrastructure
that we've been using for
years to crawl the web--
Google does a lot of that--
and makes it available to your
application for pitching and
posting HTTP content.
There's services like
our users API.
There's services like our mail
API that allows us to send
content really quickly
and efficiently.
I really would love to talk
about them, but we are running
out of time.
So what I'd like to do instead
is give you a bit of a taste
of how this runtime works in
the real world with real
deadlines, real clients,
and even really users.
So in order to do that, I'd like
to hand it over to Jason
from Potato.
Potato are a wonderful agency.
They've been working with App
Engine for quite a few years
now, I think.
And they were one of the first
people to get access to the
PHP runtime when
we were running
privately on Trusted Tester.
So, Jason we'd love to
hear your experience.
JASON CARTWRIGHT: Cheers.
Thanks very much for
inviting me along.
So hey, I'm Jason from Potato.
We're a web development agency
with a very silly name.
Based out of London.
We've got people in North
America, Europe, and Australia.
There's about 70 of US and we're
almost all developers.
So we build marketing-based web
applications, often for
marketing departments.
These are applications that
live and die around the
campaign, usually around
a media spend or
an event or a launch.
And we love using Google Cloud
Platform because it allows us
to scale up to thousands of
simultaneous users and
thousands, many thousands,
of requests a second.
But also, less glamorously, it
also scales down, as well,
after the initial deluge of
users, which is a lot less
glamorous but important
for costs.
We do this with almost 70
developers but no sys admins.
And nobody carries a pager.
So let's have a look at an
existing Drupal website that
we got up and running
on App Engine.
So this is
databasechallenge.org.
And it's a site that hosts
a competition that allows
developers and artists to
visualize how US tax dollars
are spent in interesting
and informative ways.
And it and it's all built
using Drupal.
But what isn't so cool is it
was previously hosted on a
single server in a single data
center that was about to be
decommissioned.
But I think we've
just heard of a
platform the can fix that.
So let's see how our
developers, John
and Asim, did it.
So the first stage was to get it
running on the development
app server.
And as Stuart showed you before,
you're going to need
an app.yaml file for that.
This is really familiar if
you've used App Engine before
and very straightforward
if you haven't.
You've got your application
metadata and then some
[INAUDIBLE] at the bottom
that read the script.
So previously, we got
it up and running.
And then we found out that the
previous installation using
Apache was using htaccess files
to redirect the URLs so
that the Drupal permalinks
worked.
That was really easy to solve.
We just put a router script at
the top of the application to
give Drupal the information
it was expecting in
the place it expected.
From there, we took a standard
MySQL backup dump, just a big
fat SQL file, from the live
production database.
We then uploaded that to Google
Cloud Storage, very
straightforward, and then from
there, it's one click to get
that into Google Cloud Sequel.
Then we change the connection
string.
So, just Stuart showed you, very
straightforward if you've
used PHP before or other
scripting languages.
Just a string that tells the
script where the data is.
And then, it's just one command,
like any other App
Engine application, just one
command to hand off your code
to Google and for them to run
it across as many server
instances as is required.
So we gave the site a bit of a
load test just to see what
would happen.
And we gave up trying
to break it at about
800 requests a second.
It didn't go down.
And also today, I just found
out it's using Memcache.
We did nothing to set that up.
It just works right out the
box without us even
knowing about it.
Which is really cool.
Overall, we're really impressed
by how a young platform--
and we were using before
it was released--
was able to take this relatively
complicated content
management system with
customizations on top and
scale it up.
ANDREW JESSUP: So now you've
seen Wordpress, now you've
seen Drupal running on
App Engine, too.
That's pretty cool.
So this week at Google I/O we've
announced App Engine
into limited preview.
So what does that mean?
Well, first of all, it means
that both the documentation
and an early version of the SDK
are available today from
our developer site.
That's--
can't quite read it there-- but
that's developers.googl
e.com/AppEngine.
So you get both of
them right now.
And you could use that to start
developing stuff locally
on your own machine.
For a limited time, to
actually deploy an
application, you will need
to be white-listed.
To do that is very,
very simple.
Just head on to
cloud.google.com/AppEngine/PHP.
There's a self-service
site to get set up.
And we'll be white-listing
you as soon as we can.
If you're actually physically
at Google I/O today, then
there's some great
stuff going on.
You can find both Stuart and
myself in the Developer
Sandbox after this event.
We'd love to have a chat to
you and answer any PHP
questions we don't
get to right now.
And also, for those who are
sticking around tomorrow, we
have a code lab.
And again, both Stuart and
myself will be there.
And we'll be going through a lot
of the techniques and all
of the libraries we talked about
today in more depth.
And again, we'll be
able to questions.
So now we would like to take
it over to questions.
So we've got-- again, for those
in the audience-- we've
got a couple microphones up
here, which if you come up to
I believe will be turned on
and you can ask questions.
Do we have any online
questions?
STUART LANGLEY: We
don't, Andrew.
ANDREW JESSUP: Beautiful.
So it's open to the floor.
AUDIENCE: When you run Wordpress
on any server,
typically there are
many plug-ins.
And Wordpress itself
gets updated
automatically these days.
So when you just see the web
console, it says there is an
update, click to update, and it
automatically downloads and
just updates itself.
So how does it work in
App Engine context?
Because in App Engine, there
is no file system.
So does the same functionality
work?
Or do I have to go back to the
old SVN method of downloading
updates on the back channel and
pushing updates into the
App Engine?
STUART LANGLEY: Essentially, an
engineering question, there.
So my understanding is does the
update feature that's part
of Wordpress, where you can just
point it at the zipfile
for plug-in, for example, and
have it upload and install the
plug-in in your environment
work on App Engine?
AUDIENCE: That's part of it.
But the second one
is, let's say--
my primary question was, if
Wordpress gets updated, say
from 3.3.1 3.3.2, we don't
need to manually push the
updates [INAUDIBLE].
Wordpress can automatically
download it by itself.
STUART LANGLEY: Sure.
OK.
I think so.
I believe I understand
you question.
So the answer for bothm as
Andrew already mentioned, in
App Engine environment, you
can't write to the local file
system where we serve your
application from.
And as it stands at the moment,
we will not let you
execute files that you put
in Google Cloud Storage.
We treat them as URLs.
And we don't let you
include them.
So to update the plug-ins that
you may have, or to add new
plug-ins to your runtime would
mean re-pushing your
app, much like FTP.
And the same thing for migrating
from one version of
Wordpress to the other.
You would need to re-push
your application.
Before you sit down, I believe
we have some swag for question
answerers at the front.
Please come and collect.
ANDREW JESSUP: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
presenting PHP on App Engine.
I have a question about
using Framework.
I make application with PHP
and so many frameworks.
For example, Symphony
or CakePHP.
If you tried it, please tell me
what happens if I use some
frameworks in App Engine.
ANDREW JESSUP: So we haven't
spent a lot of time
experimenting with frameworks
on this, yet.
STUART LANGLEY: We haven't.
But a few trusted testers
have taken things
like Drupal, for example--
there was a blog post last
night, and actually had a
stand up Drupal.
And people have started looking
into Symphony, Cake,
and so on and so forth.
But personally, we haven't
tested them a great deal.
And I think part of this project
is working closely
with the communities that write
these frameworks and use
these frameworks to understand
what needs to happen on our
side for them to work and also
to help them make their
frameworks run well
on App Engine.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you very much.
ANDREW JESSUP: And just
a quick public service
announcement.
If there's anyone who would
really like to be
white-listed early.
We have a very small, limited,
I think 10, invites that we
can give out.
STUART LANGLEY: I believe
that we were going to--
the question askers were
automatically going to get
white-listed.
So you're doing the right thing
in the line, there.
If we don't get more than 10
question askers, come and find
us and we'll do our best.
To the left.
AUDIENCE: So you showed an
example of Drupal and showed
an example of Wordpress.
And you said that it was
next to no changes
that you had to do.
One of the big things on both
of those is they have file
uploads and I know you've done
a good job of just having URL
handlers for that, but both
Drupal and Wordpress require
you to then say what the
URL path to those are.
And if it's on Google
Cloud Storage
it's going to be elsewhere.
And if I'm not mistaken, the
default for Google Cloud
Storage is not to be
publicly readable.
So wouldn't you have had to make
changes to that in order
for file uploads, even though
they'll be going into Google
Cloud Storage to work?
ANDREW JESSUP: So we're
actually, certainly in the
case of Wordpress, and hopefully
in the case of
Drupal, we're looking
into plug-ins that
can help with that.
So there are, for uploading
media, for example and
uploading other types of files
to Google Cloud Storage,
that's something that, while
the Wordpress itself won't
necessarily do out of the box,
it's something that could
quite easily be solved
with a plug-in.
In the case of Wordpress, that's
something that we're
working with a few people in the
Wordpress community to try
and bring to bear.
And we would like to
see the same thing
with Drupal, as well.
STUART LANGLEY: From
the right.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm
a PHP developer.
I'm also a Ruby on
Rails developer.
I was just wondering--
I use various platforms, such
as Heroku and Cloud Foundry.
I was wondering, when will you
guys support Ruby on Rails?
ANDREW JESSUP: So that's
a great question.
AUDIENCE: The thing is with
PHP, there's so many
frameworks.
You have [INAUDIBLE], Wordpress,
and all these other
frameworks.
But with Ruby on Rails, you
have Sinatra and Rails.
ANDREW JESSUP: Rails
is a great runtime.
The work for us doesn't stop at
PHP, just as it didn't stop
with Python or Java.
We're always working on more.
And we're always looking
into new runtimes.
So expect more from
this space.
I can't, unfortunately, talk
about things that we haven't
announced yet.
But expect more to come.
AUDIENCE: Where can I follow
for news regarding
development?
ANDREW JESSUP: So there's a
couple places, actually.
The Cloud Platform blog that
we announced recently is a
great place to start.
We have a Google+ profile,
as well.
And then on top of that, the
forums, as well are a great
place to find out.
The forums, actually, there were
some people on the App
Engine forums that found out
about the PHP runtime before
we'd even announced it.
So if you want to find the real
early news, I'd recommend
that as a place to start.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
STUART LANGLEY: So I believe,
unfortunately,
we've out of time.
I understand a lot of people
will want to ask questions and
get white-listed.
Please don't think that
we're trying to stop
you from doing that.
Come and find us outside.
And we'll do our best
to get that done.
So thank you all for
coming today.
[APPLAUSE]